the original Bachelorette Trista renews
our vows with Ryan you all stand with me
the moment perfect in every way
Trista and Ryan with their two
youngsters cameras abound capturing
every joyful minute but here's what only
et's cameras captured the moment the
ceremony was almost cancelled and I
pulled out my vows from before it
started when we asked Ryan about his
vows I really liked the vows that I said
the first time with that the tip as our
cameras rolled if I we decided at the
condo not to John period cuz I didn't
bring mine I saw yours there I thought
you know when I left them there cuz we
said we were gonna do them I don't I
don't remember having that conversation
I thought we just weren't writing new
ones okay I don't know what we're doing
with our Valerie lots of drama unfolds
way before The Bachelor loves stories
air Sunday on ABC for me it's gonna be
more pasta we're kind of gonna meet in
the middle of night when it sounds like
that's what marriage is all about
compromise ha ha ha ha
a few other candid moments you'll only
see on ET the two kids of Blakeslee and
max huddling by a smartphone perhaps
posting something on Facebook Trista
does social butterfly as guests play
paparazzi then she poses for the wedding
photographer will hire her
Ryan with a last-minute hook for his
daughter I was a little nervous on the
drive over here I'll admit but I think
it's more excited nerves
one vicious this is our life now so
we're really